hello and welcome to this video playing
paranoid paranoid yeah okay let's see
what we get in the Dutch this line I've
had on the board quite a bit in recent
times on video usually being quite
satisfied with the positions each 6mm
can do I want to take this on keep the
bishop well this is not a bad spot for
the piece ok so I wonder if h3 is making
some sense to keep this piece but it
also weakens the King position so not
sure about it ok bit surprised about 97
dot when to put it here
I interesting them if i go to g3 well i
can still do it I probably I should have
played age 3 at some point now that I
think of it ok whether I don't think
that anything bad happened but I very
likely could have played her played this
better um so what to do now here I don't
like this the state of this Bishop here
that is kind of it's kind of a tricky
spot again I just get rid of the central
last night and it just it's very
unnerving yeah he still has issues with
this Bishop 1c8 so and i have this f3
idea to open up his King position
okay that I'm happy about it's just a
very nice piece only five I even traits
it Wow okay hmm it's an interesting
interesting decision here take on c5 is
also also move that makes quite some
sense I would absolutely like you like
to play like f4 here or some f4 pawn
takes rook Teague's okay I'm not totally
sure but I'm going to go for this I
should do any Primos I mean taking one
of three years kind of what else kind of
decision but playing work every pre-move
it's a more than risky
okay well I thought it is a what else a
decision but opponent believes some
other things differently okay I'm going
to grab more space here before this may
be a five not sure about the timing down
how to do this one interesting thing
that I can try is put the coming on h4 i
think i'm going to do this and then
later open up the position yeah this is
an interesting situation what to do now
Queen g5 is also interesting just to
open up the whole thing but of course I
can I can also just just take g3 is also
a good move let them take and put the
night on g3 and it's actually quite
interesting let's do it I'm taking too
long him I haven't played much blitz
only a live session yesterday and on
vacation I didn't play a single game so
I'm even slower than usual kind of
enjoying the commentary but they're
taking taking more time with the with
doing it yeah what is the right play
near kingi to maybe you look h1 h3 and
as this looks good maybe I shouldn't
have played before in the first place
but it's okay it cannot be a totally
wrong move okay now he takes it
I still have to be five break I mean 93
is just an additional option that I'm
happy to have but the principled way
forward here is still on to shoot for be
five I also can just open up the whole
thing with with h3e this is also
something that I should keep keep in
mind maybe maybe i should actually do
this kind of reconsidering it all the
time what I'm going to do it it's just
that you have a couple of attractive
options you sometimes have a hard time
to decide what to do aiming for h3 here
and and now i can go age three about
like just recapture the iit I happening
maybe s this is exactly new golf the
bishop okay so he's right he will get
the bishop around some switching back to
the other idea behind I don't know not
going to make it draw here of course I
can also go at five the thing is if you
don't have a totally clear idea what to
do the time can be become quite an issue
now aged 3 is okay so switching
switching to the other side
yeah it's all very nice but winning this
in this kind of time it's not easy at
all if possible to do this actually not
easy check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check check yeah I'm a little bit
a little bit too slow at the moment here
after my break from playing yeah it was
a very one-sided game where white was
always very much clearly better but I
just I just took too long shuffling
around deciding on what to actually do
you know around here it's it's it's very
very difficult to say from with the
perfect play black is able to hold its
it's not another fun task now I doubt
that black can hold is just a day
absolutely out of this world bad bishop
it's some get the antibes he just gave
this up for this counter play jab hook
tough to say I mean it was around here
edge g4 is this a terrible move simply
for my I mean you have to chain one of
three the only reason not to take on a
three would be some tactic i like this
is immediately terrible which is
possible the computer actually actually
check beliefs that i'm winning him yeah
i saw this position and thought would
have one install maybe it is too bad him
he has to go g form and up came yeah
maybe he has to yeah now this position
is just terrible for black so we can
show it's between good options i think
this was okay it was an interesting way
of playing with this double bond i have
the age three option and the queenside
possibilities i'm actually not quite
sure if i should have played this a 4
before but yeah here i was shuffling
around not like they had no idea had too
many ideas and i couldn't quite make up
my mind what I wanted to do ya hear h3
for example is possible that i wasn't
sure because he can take and no I'm g5
is an interesting move I didn't see that
one I wasn't quite sure what to make of
this with the bishop coming around I
mean this is still quite nice for white
but I wasn't sure if this is a
well-timed operation
in general shuffling a bit and trying a
couple of things before deciding on
something it's not a bad strategy it
just that it took took an enormous
amount of moves and end time yeah I'm
not so unhappy about the way I played
this draws a bit on the slow side but I
was always keeping this is typical edge
where you can grind this this bad Bishop
position but yeah just too slow at the
mode I need to get to get back into the
hang of things playing um playing this
some this time control okay well thanks
for watching